[موسيقى]
تقع على بعد 1600 كيلومتر من فرنسا القاره
غوادلوب او الارخبيل الفراشه كما تلقب ذات
الاجنحه متعدده الالوان
كل سنه يبحر 600 الف مسافر ضمن عوالمها
الاستثنائيه
[موسيقى]
الدليل يتكفل بمهمه نقل زبائنه لاكتشاف
ثروه جوادلوق الحيوانيه
مساحه المياه كبيره جدا كما لو انك تبحث
عن ابره في كومه قش
ليجد ما يبحث عنه قام بصناعه هذه الاداه
الغريبه
انها ليست اداه السونار بل الميكروفون
المقاوم للمياه يسمح لنا بالتقاط احاديث
الحيوانات حتى نسمعها مثل اصوات حيتان
العنبر واغاني الحيتان الحدباء
اما هذه الاصوات المسموعه الان فهي لغه
الدلافين
انني اسمع الى دلفين هناك ومعه طائر سنذهب
للتاكد
وعلى بعد اميال قليله
هناك الكثير منها نعم
مجموعه من الثلاثين المرقطه واحده من اكثر
الانواع الصديقه للبشر واكثرها مرحا
يبلغ طولها حين ولادتها 50 سم ويكبر حجمها
بسرعه يصير طولها مترا بعد عام ثم تتخذ
طول الدلافين الكبار بعد عامين
من الراي رؤيه هذه الحيوانات هي في حريه
تامه تقترب كثيرا من القوارب والبشر
تعيش الاف الانواع في هذه المياه التي تعد
من بين اغنى المياه في العالم دلفين
محيتان واخطبوطيات واسماك متعدده الالوان
وهذه السلاحف الخضراء الشهيره
ونحن نتعمق اكثر فاكثر في طبيعه غوادلو
الرهيبه نجد كنوزا اخرى مخفيه هذه الغابات
الاستوائيه تحتضن مئات الشلالات غير
المعروفه انه ممر سري حقيقي جرار وصديقه
الان نشا في قلب هذه السلسله الجبليه منذ
عده سنوات اخذا على عاتقهما اكتشاف جميع
شلالات الجزيره
رسميا يوجد 50 او 55 نهرا
وحوالي عشرين شلالا يعرفها الجميع لكنني
اعلم ان هناك الكثير مما لا اعرفه حتى
الان
رحله البحث عن الشلالات تنطلق باكتفاء
اثار ذاكره الطفوله والشيء من الحدث ثم
الاعتماد على الخريطه
سنسعد على طول هذا الخط الاخضر لنصل
تقريبا الى هنا هذه المنعرجات مثل دبوس
الشعر ضيقه للغايه لا يمكن ان نجد شلالات
بها
المغامره لا تخلو من الاستمتاع بالتنوع
البيولوجي الهائل
شجره تين اللعينه
شجره التين ذات جذور عملاقه وجدار شكلته
ثورات بركان سفيان
بعد اكثر من ساعه من التسلق
لقد اتخذنا الطريق الصحيح نظام تحديد
الموقع الموجود في عقلي لم يخيبني للمره
الخامسه التي اسعد فيها كثيرا هكذا
عشرون مترا من الرهبه والجمال وذاكره
جديده تضاف الى قائمه طويله من الاكتشافات
التي حققها هذان الصديقان
[موسيقى]
الى الشرق من الارخبيل تترامى اصغر جزيره
في غوادلو عندما راها كريستوفر كولومبوس
من بعيد ابهر بسحرها واطلق عليها اسم
لاديزيغان
بريه عذراء تجمع بين المياه واليابسه
وتمتد على مساحه احد عشر كيلومترا
على روبي يعملان على حراسه محميه الطبيعيه
لهذه الجزيره
سننزل الى الاسفل ببطء لان الطريق مائله
بعض الشيء هي واحده من اقدم الجزر في
غوادلو لا يعود تاريخ لا ديجي غاد الى ما
يقرب من 150 مليون سنه اعتقد انها كان
جزءا منفصلا لجزيره في المحيط
الهادئات ببيئه جيولوجيه فريده من نوعها
بين جميع جزر الانتيل الفرنسيه هذه
الحفريات تشهد على ذلك
لدينا هنا صدفه فقدت 80% من قشرتها
وستتفكك مع مرور الوقت
تعود الى 120 مليون سنه
هذه الطبيعه العتيقه موطن لكائنات تبدو من
زمن
تحتاج الى الحراره لتعيش وتنمو لكنها تفضل
كذلك ان تاوي الى الظل من حنين لاخر
لوب من انواع الزواحف المنقرضه تقريبا الا
في هذا المكان
يختبئ بعضها تحت القطع الخشبيه مع انه ليس
مكانها المعتاد
[موسيقى]
كانت في قديم الزمان ملجا القراصنه اما
اليوم فيعيش في جزيره لاديزيغات بضع مئات
من الاشخاص فقط
تفضلوا هذا النعيم على العالم وما فيه